managing a city requires lots of
infrastructure both physical and
technical join us in historic downtown
Austin Texas as we talk to sadhus
systems about their dot map solution for
managing projects John thanks so much
for joining us today
tell us a little bit more about sada yes
so sada kind of started with a really
kind of basic partnership with Google I
would say upwards of 10 years ago maybe
doing a little bit more kind of being
one of their trusted resellers for
Google Maps and G suite and then
ultimately Google Cloud
I think we've become one of their kind
of go to services partners in the space
where they can kind of rely on sada to
help bring an implementation of like I
said kind of Maps G suite I'm Google
cloud from start to finish
obviously Google gives these great tools
for companies to build products and and
build workflows but they don't
necessarily get into the services world
with it so they need these trusted
partners I think that have a lot of
experience and and developers and
engineers that Google can trust to help
bring those projects like again from
start to finish and allow for a proper
roll out in a proper implementation tell
me a little bit more about what dot Maps
does what are the selling points for it
yes so dot Maps is focused it's kind of
more of a niche product where it kind of
has a specific need within the city most
of these cities what they have is they
need to coordinate capital improvement
projects that are internal to the city
so those are repairs to streets and
roads and things like that signs and
signals and then they also have to
coordinate those internal city projects
with outside utility groups such as gas
and electric water and things like that
the biggest problem these cities have is
basically aligning with those utility
groups that are on the outside of the
coordination efforts within the city and
I think giving an application that
really incentivizes these groups to work
together and collaborate an easy-to-use
platform it's why we're seeing such
great ROI numbers with dot maps so what
does dot maps actually do like what is
it yeah when people use it so really at
its core dot maps is going to be
conflict resolution so really what you
have right now is you got a city that
needs to dig up you know first Street
and they have
major project but you also have these
other outside groups that need to do
work in the city in the right of way in
addition to the city so being able to
properly coordinate we know city and and
share materials and costs and make sure
that you don't have groups showing up to
a construction site
at the same day at the same time so this
is kind of like a tool to help
centralize all of those different things
going on at once to communicate them
better how is the reception been for the
tool besides just our ally reception has
been great again I think the adoption
rates speak volumes I think in d-o-t
your adoption rates or everything if you
can't get people excited and on boarded
properly to these software's they tend
to end up in kind of the I T graveyard I
kind of call it within D ot what makes
the do T in public sector as a whole
different from the rest of well private
sector I would say you know just their
willingness to take risks with some
software like I was saying I think that
they've been kind of duped to some
extent by some vendors over the the last
couple decades when it comes to software
and you know I think that they really
want to mitigate risk as much as
possible especially when you're using
taxpayer money and government money to
be know buying these pieces of software
so if you can get in there and show that
you can actually do what you're saying
and prove that out and then really
generate some real ROI numbers I don't
see there's any reason why the DoD
wouldn't continue to work with you but
it's all about proving that you can do
what you're saying that your product can
do before the city I think trusts you
enough to say let's go to some of these
more robust use cases these more high
dollar infrastructure projects things
like that and that's a big reason that
dot Maps has been so successful
absolutely I mean I think again it's all
about the ease of use of thought maps to
very again niche product and I think
there's not a lot of players that are
doing it as well as we are and if you
can get in there and you can see big
wins in cities like Chicago in Seattle
you can prove out that you can work with
any size city at that point you know
cities with a lot of one-way street
cities with a ton of construction cities
with tons of cranes and construction
management going on
those are big use cases for these cities
and there's millions of dollars at stake
and making sure that you get these
projects done coordinated
and then it really communicated out to
the public as well I think is crucial
you know the government always wants to
try and be transparent to some extent
with the public and let them know what's
going on that's why with dot maps we
actually rolled out a public portal as
well so there's a very easy to use you
know Google base map type public portal
where anybody that's you know in living
in that city can go in and actually
subscribe to their their regions figure
out when construction is gonna be
happening if I'm a business owner I can
also set up alerts and emails that will
come through
so if roads or the right-of-way is gonna
be shut down in front of my business I'd
like to know that so those are just some
of the ways that we're being or helping
I guess the government be more
transparent about what they're doing and
again just kind of keep that flow of
information going from not only the
d-o-t but also to the public as well
some will John thank you so much for
coming in and doing us more about public
sector in the cloud yeah preciate your
time thanks so much thanks for watching
and stay tuned as we continue to talk
with sada about public sector solutions
[Music]
you